je fais tout tout mon jardin sans sans
produits chimiques
aucun je cultive tout mon potager tout
mon jardin mon verger en culture
biologique se dire qu'il n'ya aucun
engrais chimiques ou canam yamissi
derquenne insecticides
[Musique]
il s'adapte et touchant sa merveilleuse
c'est une aventure créative vous avez
une âme enfin toute chose
le jardinage pour vous ça met plus un
passe temps cette situation de croix de
5 6 ans parce que je voyais mon père
faire dans ce jardin est donc jardin
j'ai trouvé le calme le charme aussi du
potager de la nature les oiseaux de
troubles des abeilles sont éparpillés
partout les pistons petits anges et j'en
étais pas de mettre des granulés qui des
deux aura le jour j'ai arrêté ça elle
est déjà beaucoup moins de pucerons et
ça s'est calmé je ne voyais plus rien
les plantes été plus malins vous avez
déjà mieux les planteurs à respirer mais
ça ce sont des tomates ce ne sont pas
des brides moi je n'aime pas les
hybrides je ne me fie les hybrides
ce sont les lits thomas d'autres frais
qui s'appelle la marne en ce très bon
ça ce sont des pieds de tomates et
j'espère qu'on arrangera mois de juin
vous les faites pousser ans et sert
messi qui ne sert qu il n'est pas
chauffée je n'ai pas tiers chauffée du
tout c'est le laisser là simplement la
chaleur d'ici
[Musique]
le français moyen même très sensibilisée
par ce qu'ils mangent de pas ce qu'ils
mangent tous les jours par tous les
problèmes dans la nature
et comme le disait le président et le
présent le commandant couche-tôt le
disait en en disant le médecin le mot de
cambronne usées ma femme merde c'est
pour ça que vous devriez défilé dans les
rues et pas pour autre jour et puis
ouvrir les yeux au gouvernement c'est
pour ça qu'il faut défiler pour ça non
on peut se battre dans la rue cela ce
soutien il m'appelle c'est la nature
[Musique]
m